tu toi michou c'est vrai que ton vrai
nom c'est miguel mattioli c'est ça mon
prénom c'est miguel moi c'est ça ouais
ouais ouais lâcher parce que tout le
monde appelait michou mimi ouais c'est
ça mais chose c'est mon surnom au
collège tu savais comme un mish qui
existait que ouais je savais pas
justement les profs ils voulaient pas
que mel watt m'appelle michon parce
qu'il pense et c'est en référence à lui
ah ouais d'accord à et oumé profil
interdit c'est mes potes de m'appeler
comme ça alors là un avoir foutu pour
ton anniversaire tas annoncé en exclu la
sortie ton ep disponible sur toutes les
plateformes
c'était une soirée de ouf on a la chance
ouais de n'avoir pu te suivre pendant
cette soirée
encore merci à tous et aux équipes
regardez michou c'est un phénomène
légaré a remis vendredi c'était
l'anniversaire du bishop et qui vient
anniversaire dit cadeau et des cadeaux
on peut dire que le jeune youtuber en a
reçu voilà une rock-star vers l'audience
a cartonné ce soir-là plus de 200000
spectateurs en simultané était au
rendez-vous et plus de deux millions
d'entre eux ont suivi une partie de la
soirée millions à 100 sur alex un record
un record d'audience pour un live de
quatre heures non-stop avec de gros
moyens et la participation de nombreuses
stars comme mc fly carlito ou encore big
flo et oli m'attendais vraiment pas à ça
la wesh finir en beauté c'est cette fois
michou qui a fait un cadeau à ses
abonnés le youtuber a présenté en exclu
les titres de son nouvel ep à la fin de
cette folle soirée
my life est le nom de le paix qui est
disponible à minuit sur toutes les
plateformes de streaming sur toutes les
plate bandes de streaming cela il s'est
passé à merveille il y avait trop de
monde
dia tout l'ami fiat ou non qui est là
j'sais pas quoi dire je sais pas quoi
dire je suis trop bien dans tous les
ennemis entre m merci d'avancé
[Musique]
zizou quand le soul et c'est vrai que
c'est à présent tu t'es lancé sur
youtube à l'époque tu faisais du déni
ouais voilà ça a tout de suite car tenez
ensuite tu as fait du coup ceux qui
connaissent rien tt sur fahrenheit aussi
beaucoup ses cinq matches c'est
l'allemande a cartonné